rain ice and snow are making it hard for
many of us to get around this morning
but in parts of California the situation
is turning dire people in California's
mountains are still trying to dig out
from record-breaking snowfall for this
time of year dangerous travel conditions
make it impossible for some to leave
their homes Jonathan Vigliotti is in
Crestline California that's a hard hit
mountain town about 80 miles east of Los
Angeles Jonathan good morning
and good morning to you Vlad and to give
you some perspective what you're looking
at here is not fresh snowfall this last
fell about a week ago and yet home after
home car after car that's a van there
are encrusted in several feet of snow a
state of emergency was declared last
week yet many people we've spoken with
say they haven't received any help since
the snow began falling about two weeks
ago
this is just unprecedented it's like
more than we've ever seen and that we
could prepare for Heather Pritchett says
she's run out of food for herself and
for her cats she's one of many people
trapped in Crestline nearly two weeks
after the snow began to come down
are still digging out from the storm and
some told us help has been slow to come
if at all the San Bernardino County
Sheriff says there's so much snow
clearing the roads is just part of the
battle we're having tractors come in and
scoop the snow having to drive it away
truck it out and a number of other
things which makes the operation much
slower
in Northern California more than 75
miles of Interstate 80 remained closed
last night as plows struggled to put a
dent in the snow-covered Highway some
areas got nearly three feet of snow in
just 24 hours
meanwhile at least a dozen people died
in weather-related incidents across the
southeast after powerful winds and rains
slammed the region over the weekend at
one point leaving hundreds of thousands
without power
power is also a concern hearing
Crestline where Lynn and Glenn Overton
told us they haven't had electricity for
11 days we do have a generator but it
runs on the gas line and our gas bill
last month was over 400 so I can only
imagine what that's going to cost
and it could be five to six more days
the overtons are being told before that
power is restored free food is being
distributed at specific locations but
with homes and cars like this people
can't get there we've seen the National
Guard here believe this they're going
door to door digging out by hand we
haven't seen a single snow blower a lot
of people Tony this morning wondering
where are all the extra resources and
help they've been promised for more than
a week now
wow it's difficult and slow work there
Jonathan thank you very much appreciate
it